Hey, welcome back to 40 Days of Holiness. This is day 31.
We're talking about holiness as beholding glory.
God's glory is like a mega theme of scripture.
God is passionately committed to his own glorious,
brilliant awesomeness, his unique glory to be shining
out and seen and rejoiced in. And this glory is beautifully, intimately
connected in scripture to holiness.
In fact, glory and holiness are used parallel a lot of times in scripture.
God's glory is holy, and his holiness is glorious.
So in 2 Corinthians 3, Paul is writing about the
glory of God's holiness and how that glory and
holiness is produced in us. And he makes this comparison that's
really interesting between the law of the old covenant of the law and the
new covenant of grace. So let's look at it in 2 Corinthians
3:7. "Now if the ministry that brought death, which
was engraved in letters on stone, came with glory
so that the Israelites could not look steadily at the face of Moses
because of its glory,
transitory though it was." So here's the idea.
Moses was in the presence of God, the glorious, holy,
face-to-face presence of God. And like a fire
poker that you plunge into the glory of the fire, and you leave it there for a
long time, you take it out, and the glory and power and light of the fire
has gotten into the poker, and it's glowing like the fire.
In the same way, Moses has been plunged into the glorious
face-to-face presence of face of God, and he comes down from the mountain, and his
face is glowing. But I want you to notice that Paul says that
this was the ministry that brought death.
In other words, the law of God, because of the sinfulness
of our character, even though the law was good and holy,
there was glory in it.
Still, the law brought spiritual death to us
because we didn't have the ability to make ourselves holy
by our own efforts.
So the law could command holiness, but it did not have the
power of Christ's blood to produce holiness in
us. So it could reveal and command holiness, but
it could not empower and produce it.
Verse number eight,
"Will not the ministry of the Spirit be even more glorious?
If the ministry that brought condemnation was glorious,
how much more glorious is the ministry that brings
righteousness?"
So he says here that another way of God dealing with his people,
a new covenant, has come along, has been revealed,
and we expect it to have glory as well because it came from a glorious
God. And he says we should expect even more of God's
holy glory in this new covenant because it has the power to
produce righteousness instead of death.
Verse 10, "For what was glorious now has no glory in
comparison with the surpassing glory.
And if what was transitory came with glory, how much greater is the
glory of that which is lasting? Therefore, since we have such a
hope, we are very bold. We are not like Moses, who would put
a veil over his face to prevent the Israelites from seeing the
end, the result of what was passing away."
Moses veiled his face because the Israelites couldn't stand the brilliance of
the glory of God on his face. They were not saved, and they were fearful.
They were scared. Moses had to veil his face to keep them from freaking
out. Verse 14, "But their minds were made dull,
for to this day, the same veil remains when the old
covenant is read. It has not been removed because only
in Christ is it taken away. Even to this day when Moses is
read, a veil covers their hearts. But whenever anyone turns
to the Lord, the veil is taken away.
Now the Lord is the Spirit, and where the Spirit of the Lord is, there is freedom."
Now, he's going to talk about how the Spirit produces this holiness in
us. Look at verse 18. All right, you ready?
"And we all who with unveiled faces
contemplate the Lord's glory are being transformed into
his image with ever-increasing glory." What is
the image of God? Jesus? What is it? It's holiness.
And when we look and contemplate, the word here in Greek is
steadfastly look into a mirror.
We are changed. So the old covenant had the law, the new has
grace. The old had our efforts, the new has faith.
The old had death, but this one has righteousness.
The old one had bondage, and this one has
freedom. The old one was hiding. This new one
is beholding. The old one was despair.
This new one is transformation. And the old
one was fading. This one's on its way down.
This one is on its way up.
This one is going away. This one's coming on strong.
This one hasn't the power to do anything but reveal and command
holiness. This one can empower and actually
produce holiness in our lives. So
I want to take a second here and just say, remember,
some people look at this covenant, and
they act like, and they talk like we're still living
here, like we have to try harder and all that sort of thing.
And other people, they say, "Well, we don't have to try hard anymore," but they
forget that there's a new covenant that doesn't just
reveal and command holiness and then leave us stuck and
powerless. It actually empowers and produces
that holiness, literally produces that holiness in our life.
We are being transformed into the same image, and it
is increasing in glory.
So you and I, if you want to increase in holiness,
you need to look up to Christ, look up to Jesus, and
consider his holiness, and think of him.
This is why the writer to the Hebrews says that we ought to look unto
Jesus, the author and the finisher of our faith,
and we ought to look to him even when we're in hard times.
Looking to Jesus and beholding and meditating on him, thinking on him,
produces his image in us.
We are transformed into his image.
Whereas Moses' glory was always fading, ours is always
increasing. Whereas Moses' glory from being in the presence of God
was always growing less because it was fading away,
ours is always getting greater. Whereas they had to be afraid to look
steadfastly at Christ, we do not have to be afraid because
Christ doesn't just command and reveal holiness, he empowers and
produces it when we look and behold and keep our
eyes fixed on Jesus and his rulership.
So the temptation sometimes is to produce holiness by saying,
"I'm going to look to my efforts."
Right? "I'm going to look to my intellect.
I'm going to look to my trying harder.
I'm going to look to my self-discipline.
I'm going to look to my willpower."
But I would tell you that
self-noticing does not particularly produce holiness.
You do have to consider yourself for a little while sometimes, but the deepest part
of holiness and the transformation that happens is when we are considering
Christ. It is not in moments of self-remembrance that we grow.
It is in moments of self-forgetfulness, when we see Christ and
we say, "Oh,
look at who he is,"
and we take on the glow. We plunged into the
glorious presence and holiness of God, come out glowing,
and that's an increasing glory that's producing more and more
holiness. I'll see you tomorrow.